Richard Gere vs Sylvester Stallone for
years there's been an apparent behind
the scenes feud between gear and
Stallone Stallone finally explained the
beef between the actors with ancient
core news in 2006 saying gear had
originally been cast as a lead in 1974's
the Lords of Flatbush but since gear and
Stallone clashed immediately during
filming gear was replaced by Perry King
Stallone recalls gear getting too rough
during fight rehearsals and spilling
greasy food all over Stallone's punts
Sly claims to this day he seriously
dislikes me he even thinks I'm the
individual responsible for the gerbil
rumor not true but that's the rumor hey
just relax Amigo you want to talk we'll
talk I'm a sucker for good conversation